hello readers today it is a time for
action
yes sound the horn of action because
today we're going to be talking about
character actions in stories
understanding what characters do is key
to your success as a reader the way
characters behave towards themselves
towards others towards objects can tell
us a lot about them and can give us
clues to the larger messages in a story
character actions are what drive a story
forward
let my co-worker kim read you a story in
which nobody takes any actions
once upon a time there was a magical
kingdom
in which nobody ever did anything
nobody baked bread or called their
friends on the phone or played video
games or soccer or basketball or
wrote books or ate yogurt they didn't
even nap
they just sat there
it was a very boring kingdom
why thank you kim without character
action there is no story
let's try that again i'll blow the horn
of action and kim you do that again but
this time let's throw in some character
decisions alright lights
camera
horn of action
[Music]
the magical kingdom of bel chantry was
abuzz with activity bakers baked
ballers shot hoops yogurt smiths made
yogurt the young princess lulabelle
practiced her swordplay
and in a gray tower on the outskirts of
town an evil wizard put the finishing
touches on a spell that would bring
terrible darkness to the land
see now that's a story i want to hear
character actions and decisions have to
drive the story it's about what
characters choose to do not just about
the world around them
there could be a big scary storm
but that's not character action
it's about how the characters react to
the storm that matters that shapes the
story what do characters do in times of
trouble or when their friends need help
that's when you can learn the most about
them
actions speak louder than words after
all
what motivates these characters why do
they act the way they act what are the
values or beliefs that drive them what
are their goals and what does that tell
us about the message of the story
sometimes characters don't behave in the
way that we expect like villainous
characters may seem nice in order to do
evil things
if we think about the three little pigs
right if the big bad wolf is going door
to door and saying hello little pig it's
me your new neighbor the uh the small
nice wolf and i brought you some cookies
if you're the pig looking out the window
like you should open the door right eek
no the wolf is trying to trick you lock
the door what's interesting about
looking at character actions as they can
help us see how characters change
throughout a story in the film moana the
demigod character maui begins as a
selfish tricky character but by the end
of the movie he's changed and he cares
about moana and helps her we can see
that because of his actions he begins by
stealing moana's boat and stranding her
on an island and he ends by sacrificing
his magic fishhook to help her sorry for
moana spoilers
characters in stories can be complex
just like real people the way they
behave might surprise you and if it does
ask yourself why is this a surprise
why is this character behaving in this
way
look for evidence throughout a text to
help you understand the way characters
act
if you have insight into their thoughts
or feelings that can be a great place to
start
but for now i'm going to take action
by ending this video
you can learn anything
david out